vake is actually playing nice when he
says January 6 looks like an inside job
the fact is January 6 was an inside job
that is a fact that is not in dispute
the only reason the media is pretending
there's a dispute is because they're
lying to you case in point Capital
police officers escorted the shaman
through the building to help him locate
the Senate chambers and then open the
doors for him that does not mean that
Joe Biden and Nancy py teamed up and
colluded it means that Capital Poli
police officers who work for the
government and our law enforcement
facilitated many of the J Sixers
Misadventures I am not talking about
riers I talking about the capital police
who took selfies with people got in
trouble for it that's what an inside job
is if a bank is being robbed and it
turns out one security guard opened the
door to let the robbers in we call that
an inside job so when Oliver Darcy comes
out and says it was a conspiracy theory
he is lying to you intentionally because
he knows everything I just said